tf1 20 heures jean claude bourret iran
malgré l'ordre de kobenni des étudiants
l'ont toujours pas libéré des femmes et
des américains de race noire
le grand sud ouest 15 milliards de
francs 5 ans promet valéry giscard
d'estaing
raymond barre engagera cette nuit la
responsabilité du gouvernement sur le
débat budgétaire essuie-glaces +
chauffage plus radio plus code attention
les batteries ont des limites
une enquête de jacques collet 572
missiles nucléaires en europe pour faire
face aux forces du parc pacte de
varsovie c'est ce que réclament les
ministres de la défense de l'otan
le problème palestinien le ton monte en
cisjordanie et gaza le point avec notre
envoyé spécial jean loup demi heure
madame mademoiselle monsieur bonsoir
premier geste de détente dans les
relations washington téhéran l'ayatollah
khomeiny a ordonné la libération des
femmes et des noirs retenu en otage dans
l'ambassade des etats-unis à téhéran
depuis maintenant quatorze jours les
étudiants islamiques ont immédiatement
accepté la demande de l'ayatollah
khomeini mais en précisant que les
femmes et les noirs seraient libérés un
parent à l'issue d'une enquête
approfondie prouvant qu'ils
n'appartiennent pas au personnel de
l'ambassade pour les noms américains et
pour les femmes américaines ou les noirs
américains
après une enquête prouvant qu'ils ne se
livrer à aucune activité d'espionnage en
iran en irons le pouvoir est dans la rue
l'ayatollah khomeini tente de dominer ce
bouillonnement populaire le point avec
notre envoyé spécial à téhéran
tiré de scitivaux
moins de deux semaines la population
iranienne tout entière a fait sienne
l'occupation on pourrait parler de
mobilisation lorsque plus de cent mille
personnes se réunissent pour affirmer
que leurs droits sont légitimes et leur
exigence acceptables à ces données
politiques se mêlent une ferveur
religieuse
on traîne l'impérialisme dans la boue
tout en louant le nom de dieu
le mélange de politique et la religion
est une des caractéristiques
essentielles de la révolution iranienne
la hiérarchie religieuse qui a pris fait
et cause pour les étudiants fait non pas
de la politique mais la politique tout
court
après tant d'années de mépris et
d'humiliation
elle relève la tête et aujourd'hui elle
demeure le seul arbitre
le juge suprême ces avis sont
indiscutables elle déchaîne ou retient
donne blâme ou satisfecit la foule
attentif ne met pas sa parole en doute
et ne discute pas ces avis même si
parfois ils sont contradictoires
car comme dans tout groupe hérarchie
sait il y a des tendances des clans mais
la suprême autorité de l'ayatollah
khomeini gomme ces différents et c'est
sous sa bannière que ces dizaines de
milliers d'hommes ou de femmes se
jetteront dans les rues pour réclamer
comme les étudiants
le chat contre les otages pilier du
régime actuel les pêches dharan ses
gardiens de la révolution bras séculier
du pouvoir religieux et sont venus comme
les autres à l'ambassade américaine
proposé leur soutien et offrir leur vie
pour lutter contre l'impérialisme
pêle mêle on condamne carter sadate
béguines l'impérialisme les cigarettes
américaines
les patients sont exacerbées et il sera
bien difficile de calmer les esprits
l'union sacrée est refaite elle durera
tant que les américains seront les
otages de la population thierry de
scitivaux tf1 terran
à téhéran le porte parole iranien des
affaires étrangères a donné une version
de la libération des otages différentes
de celles des étudiants islamiques
il s'agit de tempéré immédiatement aux
désirs de l'ayatollah khomeiny et pour
ce porte parole officielle les otages
libérables de l'ambassade des etats-unis
à téhéran pourront partir dès qu'ils
seront prêts quand ils le voudront pour
le pays qu'ils choisiront dès demain
dimanche
aux états unis on suit évidemment avec
une attention vigilante ce premier geste
des autorités iraniennes
washington dominique bromberger le
communiqué qu'elle tiger se réjouit la
libération de quelques otages avec tous
les moyens dont il dispose c'est dire
que tous les autres otages
remis en liberté entre un peu plus dans
la mesure où l'on est classique le terme
étudiants les autorités de téhéran
le parlement européen a adopté à
strasbourg une résolution déposée par
cinq partis politiques dont le groupe
socialiste et le groupe des démocrates
européens de progrès cette résolution
condamne solennellement les violations
exceptionnel grave de principes
d'humanité et du droit international
ainsi que l'encouragement délibéré au
chantage et à la violence envers une
mission diplomatique
l'armée israélienne à stopper une
colonne d'une quinzaine de véhicules
privés qui se rendait à gaza venant de
cisjordanie
il s'agissait d'une délégation de maires
de cisjordanie et de leurs adjoints
c'est mère voulait protester contre
l'internement du maire de naplouse dont
les propos ont été jugés séditieux par
les autorités israéliennes qui lui
reprochent notamment des déclarations
approuvant le terrorisme la situation
est donc tendue en cisjordanie et à gaza
la grève générale a été largement suivie
par les commerçants arabes le point avec
l'envoyé spécial de tf1 jean loup de
mignot le territoire israélien des
cendres qui a été refoulé le conjoint
d'une quinzaine de voitures transportant
les maires des principales villes de
cisjordanie
lorsqu'il est arrivé aux abords de la
tente de gaza le long de la méditerranée
un barrage militaire
après avoir contrôlé les identités a
demandé au congrès de retourner en
cisjordanie ces mères avaient prévu de
se retrouver ce matin dans les locaux de
la croix rouge à gaza pour y entamer une
grève de la faim par solidarité avec
bassam chacun le maire de naplouse
arrêté j'ai deux semaines par les
autorités israéliennes et menacé
l'expression bassam chacun à lui dans sa
cellule entamé une grève de la faim tout
comme les étudiants du collège
universitaire de naplouse sa libération
pourtant à quelques exceptions près le
calme régnait aujourd'hui en cisjordanie
et bien de très présente
les patrouilles de soldats isréliens
n'était sans doute pas plus nombreuses
que ces derniers jours
en revanche à jérusalem naplouse
ramallah
la grève était presque totale comme elle
l'est depuis six jours les rideaux de
fer des boutiques étaient presque tous
baissé et demain à la demande du maire
de bethléem ces arabes de cisjordanie et
de gaza ont lancé une opération ville
morte
ce n'est sans doute que je dis que sera
examiné le cas parce comme chacun par la
haute cour de justice israélienne et
seulement alors si celle ci décide sa
libération de la tension c'est la vie
l'irak proposera au sommet arabe de
tunis mardi prochain et ne coordination
de la politique pétrolière pour faire
face aux défis sioniste c'est ce
qu'affirme est ce ce qu'écrit l' agence
d'information irakienne pour l'irak il
s'agirait d'utiliser à fond en larmes du
pétrole en faisant pression sur les pays
occidentaux qui entretiennent de bonnes
relations avec israël
le président valéry giscard d'estaing et
ce soir à paris après son voyage de
trois jours dans le sud-ouest un voyage
marqué par le discours que le chef de
l'état prononcé ce matin dans le
sud-ouest et au cours duquel valéry
giscard d'estaing a défini les grandes
lignes d'un plan régional de
développement
mais il ya eu aussi des contacts
politiques significatifs des
conversations des manifestations aussi
notamment à toulouse alors avec patrice
duhamel le bilan de ce voyage
présidentiel via c'est très clairement
le souci de dialogue qui aura marqué ce
voyage un souci qui s'est manifestée en
permanence et à tous les niveaux sur le
plan politique bien sûr avec la
traduction concrète sur le terrain de ce
que l'on appelle la cohabitation
raisonnable avec l'opposition de saint
girons à mazamet en passant surtout en
ce qui concerne l'opposition parfois et
villefranche de rouergue
le chef de l'état a fait sensiblement
progresser ce processus de décrispation
sur ce point d'ailleurs la rencontre
avec robert fabre et le ton des discours
prononcé hier à villefranche constitue
une illustration spectaculaire pour le
président giscard d'estaing la france ne
doit pas épuiser ses forces dans des
querelles partisanes qui stérilise ses
capacités et son énergie à un moment où
les difficultés internationale exige que
chacun serre les coudes
à cet égard ces trois jours dans le midi
pyrénées et les contacts avec les élus
de l'opposition auront donc et lte et au
delà des manifestations auront donc été
positif il n'y a guère de doute
l'objectif de normalisation des
relations politiques de recherche
accélérait de l'union nationale souhaité
par le chef de l'état cet objectif se
réalise peup souci de dialogue aussi
dans la préparation est maintenant dans
l'application du plan du grand sud ouest
ce plan sur lequel nous allons revenir a
été bien accueilli ce matin par les
responsables et les élus venus à mazamet
il permettra aux dix-huit départements
du grand sud-ouest de bénéficier dans
les cinq prochaines années de 15
milliards de francs supplémentaires pour
valoriser les ressources énergétiques et
agricoles pour donner une impulsion
nouvelle à l'industrie aux régionales
pour renforcer au total les bases d'une
nouvelle croissance
véritable texas français a dit le chef
de l'état
cette région du grand sud ouest a donc
désormais des moyens à l'appui de ses
atouts pense que nous allons entendre le
président giscard d'estaing dans
quelques secondes
la réussite du plan ne sera pas jugé au
nombre des mètres cubes de béton
elle se mesurera à la création
d'entreprises industrielles à la
création d'emplois à l'installation de
jeunes dans l'agriculture et dans les
zones rurales à l'arrêt même au
renforcement de l'exode des cerveaux à
l'augmentation de la part de l'industrie
et du tertiaire productif chacun chacun
de vous doit faire en sorte que ce grand
espoir ne soient pas déçus
cela dépend assurément de l'étang cela
dépend de nous
cela dépend de vous je souhaite que ces
dix ans permettent d'aboutir un succès
et je souhaite qu ensuite les
économistes les analystes d autres pays
du monde à san francisco à brasilia où à
tokyo faire ch des explications à
l'impressionnant succès que vous aurez
obtenu dans le piémont pyrénéen
vous avez pu suivre ses discours en
direct sur tf1 en débit des prêts en
début d'après midi le président valéry
giscard d'estaing a donc détaillé le
plan de développement du grand sud ouest
en voici les lignes essentielles bruno
masure 30 milliards de francs pour faire
du grand sud-ouest un modèle de la
nouvelle croissance comme l'a dit ce
matin valérie giscard d'estaing l'état
va fournir en effet 30 milliards de
francs dans les dix ans à venir pour le
développement de la région aquitaine
midi-pyrénées et languedoc-roussillon
tout d'abord développement des
ressources énergétiques c'est ainsi
qu'elle fac iten devra investir un
milliard dans les industries du sud
ouest le sud ouest qui doit devenir a
dit le président de la république
un véritable laboratoire d'énergies
douces géothermique solaire nucléaire
deuxième priorité l'agriculture avec un
gros effort sur les travaux hydrauliques
et l'irrigation de 250 mille hectares
supplémentaires en
exemple à noter également une hausse
notable des crédits d'équipement
scolaire + 30 % avec soutien aux langues
locales et une amélioration sans doute
très utile du réseau routier et
autoroutier liaison bordeaux bayonne en
80 bordeaux toulouse en 82
bayonne-toulouse en 85
en tout six milliards de travaux dans
les cinq prochaines années donc 4
financé par l'état
enfin poursuite de l'effort
d'industrialisation notamment sur les
industries pointe c'est ainsi que
toulouse sera le siège du premier salon
des techniques du futur
les députés socialistes ont déposé dès
ce matin une motion de censure avant
même que le gouvernement n'est engagé sa
responsabilité sur le budget la
constitution prévoit en effet que le
gouvernement peut engager sa
responsabilité par exemple à l'occasion
du budget et que si aucune motion de
censure déposée le texte à propos duquel
le gouvernement à engager sa
responsabilité est considéré comme
adopté sans vote en déposant la motion
de censure avant même que le
gouvernement engage sa responsabilité
sur le budget on peut considérer que le
parti socialiste veut censurer
l'ensemble de la politique du
gouvernement
le parti communiste envisage lui aussi
de son côté le dépôt d'une motion de
censure mais uniquement sur le budget et
après que le gouvernement engage donc sa
responsabilité devant le parlement en ce
moment même monsieur raymond barre doit
être à l'assemblée nationale où nous
allons faire le point en direct avec un
affirme bac
en ce moment il y à un entracte une
suspension de séance
en attendant le dernier acte le
dénouement en effet depuis plusieurs
jours la fin de cette session budgétaire
et un peu écrite comme une dramatique
jusqu'à présent chaque formation
politique a eu le droit à son monologue
pour préciser ses positions
un seul acte n'a pu être joué celui de
la concertation entre le rpr et le
gouvernement
alors pour éviter les longues heures
pour éviter les mauvaises réplique le
gouvernement tout à l'heure par la voix
de son premier ministre proposera
d'écrire le mot fin en engageant sa
responsabilité
cette solution permettra au gouvernement
de faire passer son texte
cette fin permettra au rpr de dire je
n'ai pas voté le budget donc de se
démarquer davantage du gouvernement
cette fin mettra aussi en évidence les
divergences de l'opposition en effet le
parti socialiste a déposé ce matin une
motion de censure seul et ce soir cette
nuit le parti communiste en déposera une
haussé de motion de censure seront sans
doute discuté mardi prochain mais au
fait tout cela c'est de la politique
l'important est de savoir que quoi qu'il
arrive la france disposera dans les
jours à venir d'une loi de finances est
que chaque français payera des impôts et
bien entendu à propos de toute cette
affaire budgétaire et la boîte beaucoup
été question de l'article 49 alinéa 3 de
la constitution françois lambert nous
rappelle les termes de cet article est à
quelle occasion il a été utilisé sous la
vème république
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
stipule que le premier ministre peut
après délibération du conseil des
ministres engager la responsabilité du
gouvernement devant l'assemblée
nationale sur le vote d'un texte dans ce
cas ce texte est considéré comme adopté
sauf si une motion de censure déposée
dans les 24 heures qui suivent et votées
depuis le début de la vème république
cette procédure a été utilisé à 12
reprises à propos de six projets de loi
dans le premier cabinet de michel debré
à l'occasion de la loi de finances pour
1960 et lors du projet créant la force
de dissuasion militaire georges pompidou
premier ministre a employé cette
procédure pour la loi de finances
rectificative de 62 et pour un projet de
loi d'habilitation matière économique et
sociale
quant à l'actuel premier ministre
monsieur raymond barre il a appliqué
l'article 49 alinéa 3 de la constitution
en 1976
à propos du projet communément appelée
premier plan barre et enjoint 77
il s'agissait alors d'un projet de loi
autorisant l'approbation de la décision
du conseil des communautés européennes
sur l'élection au suffrage universel de
l'assemblée européenne
l'application de cet article de la
constitution n'a jamais entraîné la
chute d'un gouvernement
plusieurs milliers de motards venus de
toute la france se sont rassemblées sous
la tour eiffel cet après midi pour
protester à nouveau contre le projet de
vignettes
après un premier rassemblement en
présence de six députés de l'opposition
qui ont dénoncé je cite les mesures anti
jeunes prises par le gouvernement
les motards se sont répandus dans les
rues de la capitale où il continue ce
soir a provoqué des embouteillages
manifestations également toujours à
paris cet après-midi de six à dix mille
personnes qui se sont rassemblées devant
le palais bourbon pour protester contre
la loi sur l'avortement
l'avortement est un génocide un
assassinat pouvait-on lire sur certaines
pancartes
une autre manifestation en faveur de
l'amélioration cette fois de la loi sur
la contraception et l'avortement a eu
lieu également cet après midi à la porte
de pantin
une manifestation organisée également
dans 25 grandes villes de france sous
des formes diverses à l'appel du parti
communiste français
entre l'europe de l'ouest et celles de
l'est le déséquilibre militaire est
considérable c'est l'europe de l'est qui
domine et pour faire face à ce
déséquilibre militaire
les ministres de la défense de l'otan
c'est à dire de l'organisation du traité
de l'atlantique nord se sont réunis
cette semaine à l'ail
ils ont recommandé l'installation en
europe de 572 fusée nucléaire pour
rééquilibrer les forces de l'otan face à
celle du pacte de varsovie
une analyse de notre envoyé spécial
permanent en allemagne fédérale
bernard wolker les ministres de la
défense de 11 pays participaient à la
réunion du comité des plans nucléaires
de l'otan
fidèle à l'attitude adoptée par le
général de gaulle la france n'était pas
représenté les ministres ont constaté
l'accroissement du déséquilibre entre la
panoplie nucléaires soviétiques et
celles de l'otan
l'urss installe en ce moment en europe
des fusées ss20 d'une portée de 4500 km
transportant trois charges nucléaires
une seule de ces fusées peut détruire
par exemple bruxelles rotterdam et
anvers plus de 100 ss20 sont déjà en
place
le commandement soviétique dispose
également d'un nouveau bombardiers
supersoniques le bac faire
équipés de missiles de croisière
nucléaires en face l'otan n'a que des
armements vieillot par exemple le
missiles pershing un qui ne porte qu'à
700 km et les avions f 111 stationnés en
république fédérale allemande depuis
plus de dix ans il s'agit donc pour le
temps de rétablir l'équilibré des forces
en europe
le comité des plans nucléaires a en
conséquence décidé de recommander à la
conférence divers des ministres des
affaires étrangères de l'otan qui se
réunira le mois prochain de décider
l'installation en europe de 572 missiles
nucléaires nouveau à partir de 1983 il
s'agirait de 108 fusées pershing 2 d'une
portée de 1800 km montée sur une rampe
mobile comme le s20 et de 464 missiles
de croisière sorte d'avion sans pilote
très précis
ces engins seront payés par les états
unis qui en auront le contrôle et seront
installés en grande bretagne en
république fédérale allemande en italie
en belgique et aux pays bas
cette décision de
temps n'est pas une réponse négative aux
récentes propositions soviétique de
limitation des armements en europe au
contraire l'otan pourra négocier dans de
meilleures conditions avec le rss si
elle ne se trouve plus en état manifeste
d'infériorité comme c'est le cas
actuellement
nous pensons que tout en poursuivant une
politique de détente et nous espérons
qu'après les accords soldes on pourra
imaginer une troisième phase nous
appelons déjà maintenant sol 3
nous devons cependant faire cet effort
pour partir la négociation des ans sur
des bases plus les flux rss
elle a déjà fait l'effort il est donc
vraisemblable qu'en dépit de la campagne
lancée par moscou contre le renforcement
de l'otan des négociations sur la
réduction des forces en europe vont
enfin s'engager sérieusement l'an
prochain le secrétaire d'état américain
a d'ailleurs précisé que l'otan pourrait
modifier ces plans si l'attitude de
l'urss permettait de réduire le nombre
des missiles déployés en europe en
réponse à la décision soviétique de
retirer 20 mille hommes émile chars
d'allemagne de l'est
les états unis annonceront d'ailleurs le
mois prochain le retrait de 1000 charge
nucléaire d'europe
même inquiétude pour le général
alexander haig ancien commandant en chef
des forces alliées en europe
le général est gay précisément venu à
paris pour participer au colloque
organisé par notre confrère le figaro
sur les problèmes stratégiques européen
le général aig a précisé à jacqueline
dubois son sentiment sur l'éventuelle
efficacité du parapluie nuque et le
nucléaire américain
autrement dit les états unis
prendrait-il la défense de l'europe
si les pays de l'est attaquer l'europe
de l'ouest
si nous conservons notre sévère
stratégie web vis-à-vis de l'union
soviétique alors dans la première
décennie des années 80 la force de
dissuasion américaine ne sera plus
crédible aujourd'hui la question de la
protection américaine d'europe ne se
pose pas les trois cent mille américains
et leurs familles stationnées en europe
sont
pour la garantir l'europe est-elle en
danger aujourd'hui je pense que tous les
fils d'occidentaux qui partagent les
mêmes règles de valeur ainsi que tous
les pays non alignés qui eux aussi
portent hcme valeurs seront menacés
quand que l'interventionnisme légal qui
se déroule aujourd'hui sous les auspices
de l'union soviétique ne sera pas
stoppée réponse aux ingérences direct ou
par pays interposés en afrique au
moyen-orient ou ailleurs mais pourquoi
pour les bus aurait telle envie de
dominer le monde
il ne s'agit pas de vouloir dominer le
monde les intérêts soviétiques sont
continuellement en expansion qu'ils ont
des visées impérialistes
il n'y a pas de doute à ce sujet depuis
trois ans nous avons été témoins de ce
qui s'est passé en angola en ethiopie au
sud-yémen leurs efforts sans verser le
statut souris yémen du nord ainsi que la
capacité centenaire en afghanistan ne
sont pas passées inaperçues en
afghanistan ils ont essayé de supprimer
le mouvement de libération
ils ont envahi le cambodge au moyen de
15 division régulier à vietnamienne
interposés et je les changements
possibles statu quo soviétique dans
l'hémisphère ouest nous préoccupe
également
c'est aujourd'hui je pense que seule la
france a eu la prévoyance et le forage
de s'attaquer à l'interventionnisme qui
se déroule dans le firent monde et nous
l'avons constaté dans plusieurs régions
d'afrique et je pense que nous ne
devrions pas laisser farid seul devant
ces tâches le général est gagnent on
sera dans quatre ou cinq semaines s'il a
pris la décision ou non de se présenter
comme candidat à la présidence des états
unis le 33e congrès national de la licra
la ligue internationale contre le
racisme et l'antisémitisme s'est réuni à
paris ce samedi jean pierre bloch le
président de la licra s'est déclaré
frappé par la remontée en france du
racisme anti arabes et anti juif
les travaux de lalique à reprendre
demain et se termineront par un banquet
présidée par madame simone veil
présidente du parlement européen
à noter qu'à strasbourg la nuit dernière
deux engins incendiaires ont été jetés
contre la synagogue de la paix
l'attentât qui n'a pas été revendiqué
n'a pas provoqué de dommages
le rapport annuel de la commission de la
qualité des émissions radios télévisions
vient d'être publié tf qui avait obtenu
une note moyenne de 12 et demi sur 20
l'année dernière gagne un demi point et
atteint la note de 13 sur 20 en 1975 tf1
avait obtenu 10 et demi puis 12 en 1976
douze ennemis en 1977 78 et 13 cette
année la note de tf1 est donc en hausse
constante et nous espérons encore faire
mieux l'année prochaine
90% des conducteurs français allument
leurs codes en ville et malgré une
polémique qui s'est développée à ce
sujet la quasi-totalité des conducteurs
applique donc la loi mais certains
d'entre eux se posent la question de
savoir si rouler en code ne puisse pas
systématiquement la batterie pour le
savoir jacques collet a mené son enquête
auprès de spécialistes de l'automobile
depuis qu'il doit rouler en code sitôt
la nuit tombée l'automobiliste français
découvrent des évidences une voiture est
d'autant plus visible qu'elle est plus
généreusement signalés par les faisceaux
lumineux de ses phares ceci pour
l'aspect positif
en revanche lorsqu'il est insouciant de
l'état de la batterie de sa voiture et
ignorants de la consommation électrique
propre à chacun des accessoires qui
l'utilisent
l'automobiliste découvre parfois avec
fureur les limites de la petite centrale
électrique qui alimente son véhicule car
une voiture française de cylindrée
moyenne produit environ 10 ans perd à 12
200 tours minute c'est à dire lorsque le
moteur tourne au ralenti 30 ampères à
30000 tôt minutes c'est à dire grosso
modo 90 km heure et quarante ans père
lorsque le moteur tourne à 4000 tours
minutes
c'est à dire lorsque la voiture avance
par exemple à 120 km/heure nous avons
donc mesurée à l'aide de nant permettra
lecture directe les consommations
propres à chaque sollicitation de la
main
en additionnant volontairement toutes
ses consommations les unes aux autres
moteurs arrêté le seul fait d'ouvrir la
portière consomme 0 29 ans perd 6 de
surprendre 1000 contacts on assiste à un
débit de 6,6 en perd allumer les feux de
position fait grimper cette consommation
à près de neuf ans perd les codes sont
de loin les plus gourmands puisque l'an
permettre annonce à ce moment 19 ans
perd en revanche les phares sont moins
voraces puisque le niveau redescend au
dessous de 19 ans perd les autres
accessoires provoque un véritable bond
de la consommation électrique puisque
par exemple le ventilateur de dégivrage
du pare-brise fait atteindre le niveau
de 21 ans père et le désembuage de la
lunette arrière 27 ans père et demie 6
noeuds sur quoi on utilise
l'allume-cigare on atteint 32 ou 33 ans
père l'essuie glace s'y ajoutant on
arrive en limite de la consommation
possible avec plus de 35 ans père en
définitive l'enlever que crée le
l'allumage des codes
en fait c'est effectivement le nombre de
pannes
lorsque la batterie est en mauvais état
mais il faut absolument savoir que si le
fait d'allumer les projecteurs
croisement créer des pannes c'est pas ne
serait arrivé de toute façon quelques
jours ou quelques semaines plus tard et
elles sont dues uniquement en grande
partie en tout cas à la qualité de la
batterie en conclusion le bon sens le
plus élémentaire commandes entretenir
régulièrement sa batterie en vérifiant
les niveaux et éventuellement en la
faisant remplacer lorsqu'elle est trop
fatigué l'éblouissement provoquée par
les véhicules que l'on croise n'est dû
évidemment qu'à l'absence de correction
du niveau des phares alors que toutes
les voitures modernes sont désormais
équipés d'un dispositif qui évite s'il
est bien utilisé cet inconvénient
oui on oubliait pas de faire régler vos
codes parce qu'il a beaucoup qui
éblouissent c'est vrai le temps demain
dimanche sur la moitié ouest quelques
pluies sur la moitié est du soleil
demain après midi encore du soleil sur
l'ouest et le nord-ouest risques de
chutes de neige sur les vosges le jura
les alpes et sur les pyrénées à partir
de 1700 m à 23 heures le dernier journal
avec daniel du goût bonsoir et merci